guys the jurassic world dominion trailer
is here we're here to cover this i'm so
excited i'm really really looking
forward to this movie couldn't have
dropped at a better time you covered
peacemaker at midnight you stay up all
night going batman tickets are going on
sale is it gonna be like spider-man no
way home and then they drop this to help
us pass the time
awesome
hell yeah universal you did good this
time leave a like if you can let's get
into it people
[Music]
i wanted to show you something that
wasn't an illusion
how we've grown
something that was real
mario
something
see
and touch oh she's back
why is it gonna be crazy
live
we'll find a way
i love the winter setting
we can't keep her here forever
they find their one
that's our job
damn straight
humans and dinosaurs can't coexist
become an ecological disaster
wow
you don't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
you coming or what
wow
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
okay that was that that's very cool
we're supporting the church
[Music]
come back i always come back
dancers
wow
wow
the da vinci code jurassic mission
impossible dominion
it's another plane right
not exactly
definitely
holy christ
i am loving this so much
wow
why do they always have to go bigger
and malcolm
that was awesome
[Music]
that just made me so happy now you got a
good early birthday present that time
john yeah maybe this one will be good
it looks like such a blast
that looks like a freaking blast that is
a terrific trailer oh my goodness i will
say that is a terrific trailer they're
really doing something different with
jurassic park this time i love it man
i'm not a big fan of fallen kingdom i am
a champion for jurassic world i thought
that movie was so much fun a roller
coaster and this feels like an even
bigger roller coaster they're truly
following through with the way it ended
with fallen kingdom and now we're in the
future a little bit more and dinosaurs
are coexisting amongst humans can it
work and then come on they're really
utilizing our legacy characters you got
luke han and leia right there yeah we're
home chewie it's so exciting to see all
three of them share the screen again not
since the first jurassic park they've
been teasing us and jeff goldblum and
the second one jeff goldblum fallen
kingdom allen ellie in part three now
they're all back together i'm so glad
they gave us that money shot of them i
mean that's that's that's going to sell
all the tickets right there that's all
anybody wanted to have confirmed for
them i mean even but the thing is even
if they weren't in the trailer i would
this this movie has my money it's coming
out in june um
i thought it was next year june oh wow
that's so soon get your tickets so soon
it is right around the corner well i
mean it's been a long long time coming
and obviously pandemic delays but yeah
there's something you know i i refresh
it does seem fret i i i've you know have
various reasons in the back of my mind
to be cynical because i'm not a big fan
of the jurassic world movies in general
but each time they put out a trailer
they get me and this is my favorite
trailer of all three hands down i mean i
know they're multiple trailers but this
yeah i looked so kind of moody and
exciting and yes it has your legacy
characters but what's getting me going
was just seeing the snow and the you
know
environments yeah seeing them as actual
animals in situations that you associate
terrestrial you know current day and age
animals with people hurting them and
these more sort of rural images instead
of having it be like attacked on coda of
jurassic park 2 where it's like oh yeah
they're in human society for a hot
second it seems like yeah we are going
to live in that and we are going to see
what this next week it seems like we
actually might get a new status quo that
isn't just oh we really shouldn't have
done this and now it's a monster movie
straightforward not that this won't have
those things because it absolutely will
but it definitely looks like something
different from the previous two movies
but also that like you said transitions
perfectly out of the last one i am
surprised as anybody that i cannot wait
to see what this becomes it is such an
exciting trailer like this feels like
summer blockbuster it's doing all these
types of different summer blockbusters
they literally did mission impossible
dominion right here yeah with a little
da vinci code sprinkled on top they're
like in rome or something so fascinating
to see how the plot of this unfolds is
they're traveling like what is the plot
exactly is there a plot here what is the
plot or are we just like going a
location to location they're gonna
travel the globe i don't care monsters
back in the box let's see some t-rexes
in china i don't care where you go
because we gotta sell those tickets i
know let's do it from jurassic world
architect and director colin chavarro my
man
dominion takes place four years after
isla nebular
has been destroyed
dinosaurs now live and hunt alongside
humans all over the world this fragile
balance will reshape the future and
determine once or for all whether human
beings are to remain the apex partners
on a planet they now share with
history's most fearsome creatures dude
nah they would whoop
my goodness like what is this so they're
going to have like peace treaty meetings
with the dinosaurs the dinosaurs gonna
learn to talk they're gonna negotiate
alan like that's what i mean i want to
get a sense of like what what are the
scenes like because we're in the jungle
we're in the snow we're in europe we're
in the sky you know we got air tactics
attacking our plane this just looks like
pure mayhem but also has that like
wonder gloss to it and sure i guess i'm
excited for chris pratt why not he's
everyone's favorite chris if i'm not
missing you don't want owen and claire
to finish their rousing three movies
i'll tell you man um
they are not that interesting in
characters but after bryce dallas
howard's direction in the book of boba
fett i'm letting her direct one she's
not even in on camera in there but
watching her here i'm like you know i i
love you
so i'm excited to see you because you're
a good director absolutely she is all
right guys this trailer did not
disappoint i genuinely loved it that was
that was amazing it was a great trailer
gotta say hi that just made me so happy
all right well thanks for being here
and uh we'll catch you soon
you